one of my favorite places downtown las
vegas carson kitchen is known for its
creative comfort food with seasonal
ingredients and they're ready for the
spring menu
and joining us to talk about that we
have david english and scott simon with
a preview of some of the new dishes
coming up you've had the winter dishes
right and now you bring on probably some
lighter fare yeah a little bit of
lighter fare so what we've got going on
here is we're actually going to kind of
go through a little bit of what's left
over from the previous menu we've got
about one month left so we want people
to get that last opportunity to come
into the restaurant and try some of the
items that we had on the menu um scott's
going to be making the warm spinach
salad over here he's got some
caramelized
onions and a little bit of cannelloni
beans and a maple sage vinaigrette he's
going to toss the salad right over there
and then he's going to top it with a
little bit of dried cranberries and
smoked almonds over here it looks
fantastic i got to tell you the smells
here are phenomenal
this is a is this a new dish or is this
a this is actually a seasonal dish so
this will come off at the end of the
month
uh so if you want it you got to get in
there now all right enjoy the spinach
salad for sure excellent what else can
people look forward to beyond that
uh we're in the works right now of doing
a lot of different dishes uh
our first tasting of the new menu
actually starts on wednesday and then it
takes about a month to get through all
the new dishes and stuff like that but
in front of us here we have a couple of
the staples too that we go with the
bacon jam that's always on the menu
the uh
chicken breasts the chicken thighs with
the alabama white they look great and
the donut bread pudding and you brought
this out like literally seconds before
so it was sizzling yeah as it came out
what was that again that's the bacon jam
oh that's so good it's so delicious oh
we're gonna be trying it it's part of my
staple diet part of my workout that i
think that's part of the pyramid right
nutrition absolutely yeah yeah at least
at least mine it is you could see one
serving a day
exactly exactly well david how long have
you guys been in business now
oh gosh it's almost eight years now i've
been with the company just for a shorter
amount of time but scott's been there
pretty much since the beginning but uh
eight years long now so it's just such a
great place oh yeah we're very happy to
have made it through the uh the wild
cove at times there what was that like
for you guys it was tough
we opened two other restaurants in uh
salt lake city in atlanta during that
time period so a lot of challenges that
you never
learned that would be part of the
restaurant industry we but we managed to
get through it and good for you guys for
getting through that and was there a
time thank you everyone you know
everyone that comes in and supported the
story yeah for sure was there a time
where you were just uh sending out food
and not necessarily bringing people into
the restaurant yeah we had uh we had a
small like kind of pick up and take away
kind of operation going for the first
month and a half but then it opened up
pretty quickly las vegas bounced back
really quickly salt lake city is really
getting going right now too so we're
really really happy for people who
haven't been there tell them where you
are
so we're located here uh downtown on
sixth uh street it's carson and sixth
just one block off fremont street yeah
and you're pretty crowded most of the
time we are reservations are highly
recommended yeah yeah absolutely because
uh it is a great place especially lunch
i haven't been there for dinner but
lunch is the way to do it for sure if
you're if you're trying to avoid the
crowd get in a little bit early right
when the doors open and then we'll get
you out what time is that we open at 11
30. okay uh daily and then we stay open
until nine or ten o'clock we're about to
change the hours seasonally uh spring
and summer time we stay open about until
10 o'clock and 11 on the weekend and
really briefly this is my fault we
skipped over about 10 seconds to talk
about cocktails no problem here uh we're
going to go over uh it's called the bald
ass it's about 10 seconds sister no
problem it's going to be a take on a
penicillin cocktail i've already
pre-made it up here for you so it's
going to be a little ginger lemon
uh ginger shrub bakarovka which is a
czechoslovakian liqueur and then a
little bit of scotch oh man that sounds
like there's only one drink though
there's a bunch of people there i'm so
sorry for the rest of you yeah i've got
you guys off the air
i've got plenty of it so don't worry
david scott thank you so much be sure to
check out carson kitchen it really is
it's one of my favorite places
check it out downtown mercedes